ADAM EVANS: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Adam Evans.
I work in the Google Maps
API part of Google, part
of the big Google Cloud team.
This is the first of eight
sessions in the Maps track
here at Google Cloud Next.
We're going to focus
today's session
on talking about
optimizing and making
more efficient your
business operations using
Google's location APIs.
I did want to point out we have
quite a few other sessions as
well.
So if you have
questions about applying
Maps in your application
that don't get addressed
by this session today, it's a
big rich, deep suite of APIs.
Please be sure to attend
some of the other sessions.
Come and connect with some
of the folks in the Maps team
after this session.
We'd love to make sure
everybody goes home
with their questions answered.
We'll have some Q&A as well.
So today, my
colleague David and I
are going to explain why
Google believes that location
is really critical to
business operations,
talk a little bit
about trends that we
see in the use of
maps and location
in more B2B nontraditional
use cases for Maps,
beyond just looking
at visualizing a map.
Just to get a sense
of the audience
here to make sure we can
make this relevant to you,
can I get a show of
hands for those who
identify more as a developer?
And how about those who
identify more on the business
side of their business?
How about both?
Everybody is a
hybrid these days.
There we go.
OK.
That's great.
And how many of
those in the room
are currently implementing
location or Maps
tools of any kind in
their applications today?
All right.
So there's some
deep fluency here.
How many have not, but have
some interest in using location
in their tools?
All right, again, that's great.
So is a pretty
broad cross-section,
which I think gives some--
gives us an obligation to get
a little bit of broad context,
as we get started here.
The world is a really
busy place, as we know.
At Google Maps we see
a lot of businesses
asking us questions
every day about how
to make better sense
of their employees,
their customers,
their suppliers,
the operations of their
business as it moves around
in the world.
And this is an area where
Google's deep understanding
of the world and
the places in it
can be useful to you
and to your businesses.
Picture a major
city that perhaps
is trying to do urban planning,
plan traffic management, plan
the movement of people
and goods, zoning,
sprawl, expansion.
They may have invested
hundreds of millions of dollars
in capital in perhaps
expensive sensors
to monitor the movement
of vehicles over roads.
This is the kind of place where
Google's real-time traffic
information, sourced from
billions of connected devices
and connected Google Maps
phones with location opted in,
can help drive better business
decisions for that city.
We want to be able to answer
questions such as where should
we plan the next expressway?
We also want to help
individual businesses,
from the really large
corporations down
to the very small startup,
to answer questions
like where should my
salesperson plan a visit based
on density of their customers?
What is the most
efficient route for them
to visit 10 or 15 customers in
a very short visit, a layover,
for instance?
If I'm a taxi company,
how many vehicles
should I dispatch
just after midnight
on New Year's Eve, based on
historical traffic patterns?
These are questions that
Google can and wants to answer
through our location APIs.
In other words, we
want to make it easier
to bring the location
of the real world,
this high resolution,
deeply accurate,
scalable map that Google
stands up for our consumers.
We want to make that
available through APIs
so that you can
access those data
and make decisions
about your business.
Location is something
we just naturally use
to connect us, with our
friends, with our colleagues,
with each other,
with our customers.
If you think about this, think
about what's on your phone
right now.
Think about the number of
apps, hopefully in addition
to Google Maps, the mobile
app, that you use that already
natively use location.
A ride share app
like Via, who offers
$5 flat-rate rides
in New York City,
is powered by Google Maps.
How can they do
that at that cost?
Because the infrastructure
costs of building
on Google's platforms,
including our APIs,
are so low and so
efficient that they
can plan an entire ride
sharing application
around an easy-to-build
mobile app
and support from Google
and our partners,
to put together a ride
sharing application.
Think about a vacation rental
application like Tripping,
where they can provide
deep context about a place
you might want to visit,
context such as how far are
these hotels from the
places of interest
that I'd like to visit?
Google has a point of interest
database with hundreds
of millions of points
with the type of places
that might interest
you on a visit.
Do you want to visit
an amusement park?
Is there a church nearby?
Is there a place that I
can stop so my daughter can
go to the bathroom on the trip?
And speaking of
which, Google Maps
also helps to answer that--
I have a four-year-old girl
and I've had to answer that
question--
Daddy, how long until we get to
Space Mountain at Disney World?
So we can provide that
immersive experience
for location and maps.
If you've ordered a coffee
recently through your Starbucks
mobile app, you
want to make sure
that it's hot when you arrive.
A lot of people order
the coffee when they're
standing in a long line.
You can even order it in
the car on the way in.
How do we know that
coffee is going
to be hot when you arrive?
We need to know exactly
when that person is pulling
into the parking lot
so it can be sitting
there steaming on the counter.
Traffic can be pretty
bad where I live,
so if I order the coffee
in the car, on my app,
Starbucks can tell how
long it's going to be,
using Google's real-time traffic
and the predictive travel time
features, such that they
only spin up the order
so that the barista has
prepared my cappuccino just
in time that's still
ready on the counter.
The feature I really
need is, hey Adam,
you're one coffee short
of a wakeful morning.
You've overshot the place.
Here's a little warning,
and perhaps a geofence
can tell me to turn around and
go back and pick up the coffee.
So I like to ask
this question a lot.
So far I've talked about
consumer experiences
and the experiences that we
have as consumers using location
in apps.
But what does this
mean for a business?
I think from the
show of hands a lot
of people here work in
and operate businesses
that don't necessarily have a
citizen or a consumer interface
as their primary means of
connecting with the world.
Maybe you want to
connect with a supplier.
Maybe you want to connect
with your own employees.
What does this trend
toward using location
to connect with people--
what does it mean
for your business?
Anybody have any guesses?
You can shout it out if
you know of what this
is, what we're showing here.
These are the
movements of phones.
These are the movements
of mobile phones
with location opted in
tracked for Google Maps.
And you can see the
movements through time
throughout the day.
The living, breathing
city, as people
commute generally from
the suburbs into downtown.
This is possible to drive all
those really complex decisions
about planning that I talked
about, whether it's for a city,
or for a taxi company, or
for a dispatch company.
All of these
decisions are driven
by a massive amount of data.
What's relevant here is that to
get the position of something
to within a few meters--
this is a major, major change
that's kind of happened quietly
around us in the last decade.
15 years ago, the cost to
get the position of something
within a few meters was two
or three orders of magnitude
higher than it is right now.
You used to need this
differential GPS equipment.
If you don't know
what that is, it's
like an antenna
and backpack system
that surveyors would
use to understand
where a point was on the
ground pretty accurately.
That's now subsidized by your
mobile carrier and the location
driven by every mobile phone.
And that's really done a
lot to connecting people
with the places they need to be.
But what we think
is really relevant,
and there's been a lot of talk
about the Internet of Things
and the impact that
that might have
on your business and
the world in general,
is that if devices become
connected, billions of devices,
not just phones that
natively include geolocation,
but perhaps a little
tag for my dog
who has a bad habit
of running away,
perhaps a fitness
band that can track
how far you've been running.
Maybe every single piece
of manufacturing equipment,
such as expensive
construction equipment used
on a construction site
that are prone to theft,
the tracking of
everything is becoming
cheap, an order of
magnitude or two cheaper.
And as we know, just in
general for trends that happen,
is that when something
gets a lot cheaper,
new business models become
possible and old ones get
under stress.
So the reason that we want
to talk about location
and what it means for
your business today--
we're going to show
some examples--
is that we think it's critical.
Our customers are
coming to us saying,
I need to have a strategy
to incorporate location
in my business operations
because everything
is becoming connected and
everything has a position.
Increasingly, that position is
not necessarily shown on a map.
We believe at Google that we're
entering the fourth phase,
or the fourth wave, of mapping.
Now, paper maps are
something with hundreds,
and even thousands
of years of history.
Cartography has been
around for a long time,
since the first maps created by
the ancient Greeks and Ptolemy,
all the way through
the paper maps
that your parents probably
printed out, those AAA TripTiks
that you'd have, that
big stack of paper
you'd have to take a
trip with your family.
Perhaps you started
using digital maps
through geographic
information systems,
if you work with them in
business or as a citizen you
might have started using them
with the launch of Yahoo maps
or MapQuest or when Google Maps
launched, 12 years ago now.
And then we moved
into a more dynamic,
real-time picture of the world.
The third wave, and that's
where most of us are today.
We can get a real-time
picture of where
we are, such as those apps that
I showed earlier on screen.
Automotive GPS
dashboards are now
integrated to give you a
real-time picture of where
you and all the
vehicles are around you,
in order to give you traffic.
But we think we're
entering into a wave
where location can
be more intelligent.
And the actual map--
which, let's be honest, we
don't need to always glance down
at our phone to understand
the estimated time before I
arrive at my destination.
All I need is the ETA.
Maybe I need it just
as a voice prompt.
Maybe my delivery
driver just needs
to know exactly how far behind
schedule or ahead of schedule
they are.
The directions are being given
to them through the dashboard
equipment.
So we think we're
moving to a world
where predictive analytics
and machine learning
are allowing devices, people,
and vehicles to connect
without the need to visualize
that on a map all the time.
And then ultimately,
if billions of devices
become connected, that
we'll be able to extract
some patterns of information and
learn more about our business.
And this is where we think
it's really exciting.
So the reason I've
given you this preamble
is to get to an
interesting story here.
I had the privilege of
talking to the chief operating
officer of a really
interesting software
company, small company.
And they started trying to
fill a niche in dispatch tools
for small businesses.
Now, big companies who
operate huge fleets
have long had access
to dispatch software.
That would mean telling an
ambulance or a truck driver
in a large fleet where
to be at what time
and when to pick up a
load and drop it off.
They'd have tools in
the vehicle and they'd
have tools for the dispatcher
back at the head office.
But small companies, like
a florist, perhaps a small,
mom-and-pop-shop
delivery company,
you might have two
or three trucks,
a couple of taxis to drop off
the flowers before the wedding.
They never had access to this.
So the software company
I was speaking with
built a beautiful tool.
It was a tablet that you
can buy and the software
is a service model, every month.
It came with a
telematics device which
allowed, through the
airwaves, to send
a little bit of information
back to that company
and describe where
the taxi was, describe
where that florist was, and have
the same kind of robust tools.
When we went to
speak with them, they
were using a competitor system
to Google Maps at the time.
And we said would you like
to transfer over to Google?
They said yes, but
you know, to us
visualizing that data on a
map, yeah, that's interesting.
Google Maps are great
and they provide me
with satellite pictures
that we really like
and some place information.
But Adam, what we really
want to talk to you about
is something that will make
a difference in our business.
Because the challenge
that this person had is
they had 10,000 customers.
You think about the costs
of servicing, any of you who
own a business or
operate the business,
you know how much it costs
to keep a customer happy,
informed, and serviced.
They had 10,000 customers and
they were a small company.
Their customers only
had half a dozen
or maybe 10 vehicles each.
That's 100,000 vehicles,
10,000 customers,
think about what that
means for their margins.
To grow, they had to
service one more--
10,001 customers, 10,002.
They wanted to
grow and break out.
And they said, Adam,
can Google help me?
We worked with the Google
Cloud platform analytics team
to get creative.
They said that
they had the right
to look at the movements
of all of those 100,000
vehicles in their
downstream customers' fleet.
Every two minutes, they would
ping one of those vehicles
and get a little
data packet back.
It was about 100 kilobytes.
And in there was the
speed of the vehicle,
what it was carrying--
flowers, for example--
how fast was it going, was it
parked, where was it parked,
the latitude and
longitude of that vehicle.
And all of that
position information
came back to a server.
And you think about
what that means.
100,000 vehicles, roughly
every two minutes,
that's 72 million data points a
day across the aggregate fleet.
Now they weren't allowed
to identify their customers
by name, but they took that
aggregated information,
and through some
data science, they
were able to draw statistically
significant patterns
of the movement
of their customers
to learn some great things.
Here's one of the
things they learned.
They learned that a
significant number of customers
idled longer in front
of a coffee shop
than they did in
front of a warehouse.
That's interesting.
They learned that
two-axle truck traffic
in and out of the
port of Vancouver
was greater than
four-axle truck traffic.
Now I don't know what to
do with that information.
But there are organizations
who really want
to know that kind of thing.
So think about this.
A small software company,
who had a tough margin growth
business for small mom
and pop delivery shops,
continued to run that business
and then analyzed their data
using Google platform
and location.
Keep in mind, the location
is critical for all of this.
To get the address, to get the
place type from Google's Places
API, to get all of the
contextual information required
to run that data science,
you need the location.
So they ran location analytics
on the aggregated database
and launched a new business.
They are now a data
science company,
and they sell packages of
information to a hedge fund,
to an insurance company.
And they've learned a
lot about data science
by working with Google
and working with location.
And the reason I love
that story is twofold.
One, small companies get
access to incredible technology
in a way that only big companies
used to have access to before.
But two, they did all of that
in a short period of time
and with a relatively
low cost base.
They are leveraging
the location data
from their own existing
business to learn new things.
So we think this is exciting.
So lets talk a little
bit about some use cases
here beyond that fleet company.
How tracking, in particular,
drives business decisions.
We have a lot of companies
that build asset tracking
solutions for more than
just tracking trucks.
They might track the
position of their employees,
the efficiency of
their sales force
as they go to visit different
customers in the world.
They might be
looking at optimizing
the number of vehicles
that they allocate
to a problem, such as the taxis
on New Year's Eve scenario
that I gave.
So lets look at a
few of these here.
In order to provide a great
customer service experience--
how many people in
the room here have
had that frustrating moment
where your cable company needs
to come and service
your cable, and says
please be home between
the hours of 8:00 a.m.
and next week?
Right, we've all been there.
So part of the challenge
there that that company really
runs up against-- we
know because we've
worked with some
of these companies
to improve that customer service
experience-- the challenge they
have is a logistical one.
They have one service
person who has
many service calls to attend.
And then they have the
customer, that's you.
You may be at home
hoping to have somebody
come to visit you, but they have
a delay from the previous job.
Using location to connect the
customers with the service
people is a simple thing that
can improve customer service
and make a massive difference
to your market share
if you're in a service
business like installing
cable, but perhaps even
for delivering the mail.
Customers can get
a real-time status
for the position
of their package,
if it's being tracked
in a vehicle, and even
a notification of the estimated
time before it's there.
So that you can be at work
and say, oh, delivery person
is coming in the
next 20 minutes,
I'm just going to pop home
quickly, pick up the package,
sign for it.
Companies like Fleetminder have
been using our asset tracking
platform, using our maps,
using our real-time traffic,
and our places
information, to make
their business more efficient
for their downstream customers.
And we have a great quote here
from the CIO of Fleetminder
that says Google's mapping
solution has helped them
cut their own customers'
inefficient driving in half
and reduce incorrect
deliveries by 20%.
That is the kind of
statement that you want
to make to your customers--
To say that we've reduced your
inefficiency significantly,
your fuel costs, and your time.
Another really interesting
use case for this
is the full utilization of
all the equipment out there.
If you've ever seen
a construction site,
you might notice that
there's a lot of equipment
there, anything from
the great big digger
all the way down to
a generator running
some remote lights or
a scissor jack that
allows people to work up on the
second floor in a construction
project.
This equipment is
typically rented
through a series of businesses
that maintain inventory.
Equipment gets beaten up
and needs service regularly.
And it needs to be maintained
in different inventories
around the world.
If you are running a
large construction project
and look to rent
this equipment, you
need to be sure that
the inventory is
there and available.
And it's been a major challenge
for businesses in this space
to maintain availability.
You can lose business if you
don't have equipment that's
ready and has been serviced.
This was a challenge faced
by one of our customers
who implemented tracking
devices using geolocation
on all of their equipment.
They were able to reduce theft.
They were able to monitor
the service intervals
and the number of
hours of service
that each piece of
equipment had gone through,
so that they could
be sure that when
the equipment was being
allocated to a new job,
that it was ready for service.
But the location
component was critical.
If you went to rent
equipment in Dayton, Ohio,
and it wasn't there, their
database system in the back end
needed to check the real-time
location of other availability.
So over in Cincinnati,
there may have
been the same kind of equipment
available in another branch.
That led to a massive increase
in customer satisfaction
for the business that
implemented full scheduling
and utilization by just
tracking the position
of their equipment.
By having a real-time
view of vehicles,
dispatchers can track
global orders and shipments
and have a dashboard
picture of the operations
of their business.
Now, many businesses
are doing this today,
and where Google's
really been enhancing
it has been providing
contextual information.
Is someone in front--
where are they?
I have their latitude
and longitude.
What's the address?
And using Google's geocoder,
I can get the address.
And using Google's
Places API, can now
see what type of addresses.
Are they in front
of that warehouse,
or in front of the coffee shop
idling a little bit too long?
I can get live
weather and traffic
by correlating that
position to other feeds,
and really get an accurate
picture of my business
as it is now, including
meeting dynamic customer
needs such as rerouting orders.
I want to tell another
interesting story,
working with a company that
builds small device trackers
for very sensitive goods.
Can you imagine
if you were trying
to ship a drug sample, a
package of drug samples,
or if you were shipping an
organ in the organ donor system?
These are high value goods.
They're insured.
They're insured by an
insurance company who
writes a policy based on
the likelihood of that good
to have to be replaced.
And when you're insuring
something like drug samples
or a box of Rolex
watches, you want
to make sure you understand
the risk to that shipment.
This company that we work
with makes a tracker, about
this big, and it has some
interesting things in it.
Its tracker has a
humidity sensor,
which I guess is
important if you're
trying to understand the health
of some drug samples, humidity
and temperature.
It has a tip-tilt
sensor that knows
whether the box was dropped.
It has accelerometers to know
whether it fell off a shelf
and might be damaged.
But the key thing was that
before they came and worked
with Google, the
package would arrive
you would open it up and
then find out the damage.
You would remove the
tracker, plug it in,
and understand what happened.
But it was all after
the event, and it
had a huge impact on
the customers' rate
that they paid for the
insurance of the package,
because they could not trace
where the event happened.
The liability was not known.
So the rates to insure untracked
goods were really high.
This company implemented,
through really low cost--
remember I was talking
about that trend, the cost
to find the position of
something is now cheap.
Used to be really expensive
to know where something was,
now they put a small Wi-Fi--
low battery power
requirements, and really,
really low cost to put a Wi-Fi
connector in their device.
And any time that package
moved through the world,
it might occasionally
see a Wi-Fi signal.
On your phone right now,
how many Wi-Fi hotspots do
you think you can see, roughly?
10?
20?
As these packages move
throughout the world,
they would see a Wi-Fi hotspot.
Google offers a
global geolocation
API that has a georeferenced
position for Wi-Fi hotspots.
And that means that these
devices' positions are known
as they move through the world.
So when the box was
dropped, it can now
be correlated to a position.
If the box was tipped, we
know exactly where that was.
Geofences and real-time
alerts could be sent up.
And this had a material
impact on the cost
of the insured
goods for everything
that this company provides.
They have a huge
advantage in the market
now, over their competitors,
because they implemented
location in their tracking.
Vehicle telematics are an
interesting and broad business.
We could spend an entire
session just on this alone.
Companies such as
Mojio and Dash have
built platforms,
connected to Google,
that allow a better
relationship between the driver
and the vehicle, and all
sorts of other businesses.
Including an
insurance company, who
might want to offer you a
discount on your driving
if you're a safe driver and you
don't accelerate hard, or brake
hard, or run a stoplight.
It might have a great connection
with the auto dealership.
If you go to buy
your car, you notice
how they want you to
come back for service.
I don't know about
you, but I'm busy
and I often miss my
service intervals,
and you get the occasional
phone call from the dealership.
Your car is due
for an oil change.
With an easy connection
between the car's position,
tracking the number of
miles that it's driven,
providing regular metadata
through a location connected
device, you now get
an alert on your phone
when the car's due
for an oil change.
Before you come in for
service, the dealership
has a lot more information
about your vehicle,
about how it's been driven,
If it's been driven hard,
if it's ready for
its service or not.
This allows a
better relationship
between the company
and the driver.
So I've just given a whole
lot of great use cases.
And you might be sitting
here, overwhelmed, thinking,
I don't know where to
start with all this.
Fortunately, there's
a handsome man
with a nice set of glasses
like mine over here named David
McClusky, who's going to
come up and talk about how
to think about implementing
these APIs in your application.
David leads our global customer
engineering team for Maps
here at Google.
Thanks, David.
DAVID MCCLUSKY:
Thanks a lot, Adam.
Thanks for that introduction.
So as Adam mentioned, my
name is Dave McCluskey,
and I lead customer
engineering for Maps.
Adam just talked a lot about
some very interesting customer
use cases that we are seeing
throughout our Google Maps
customer base.
What I want to do is tell you
a little bit about the APIs
that are powering some
of these experiences,
and how you can incorporate
them in your own solutions
to solve some of your
own business problems.
So what do we offer?
So we provide a suite of APIs
called the Google Maps APIs.
And Google has been
investing heavily
in building up a
consumer mapping
platform over the
past decade to build
the most accurate and
comprehensive representation
of our world.
We have made that platform
available to developers
with a suite of nearly
20 APIs that allow you
access to the
underlying location data
that powers Google's
mapping products.
So these APIs are a set
of APIs that are scalable.
We have millions of
developers using them today.
They're trusted
and comprehensive.
Now, I'll go into a
little bit more detail
of what these APIs do.
But first, I want to
show you some stats.
Google loves statistics,
or maybe that's just me.
Two million websites and apps
are using the Google Maps API
every week.
This makes the Google Maps APIs
one of the most popular APIs
on the internet.
Google has maps of
over 200 countries
worldwide, which represents
about 40 million miles
of mapped roads.
And we're providing
transit directions daily
on the order of 1
billion kilometers a day
of transit directions.
And that's drawing from
Google's real-time traffic data
that we now have in
over 100 countries.
So we have a set of
APIs that give access
to this information to you
for your own applications.
And we have APIs
for every platform.
So whether you're building a web
application, iOS application,
Android application, or a
back-end server application,
we have APIs that to allow
you to bring this data
into your own application.
So what are some of these APIs?
I'm not going to go
through all of these.
You see, we have
like 16 APIs here.
But I'll go through
some of the highlights
and then I'll walk you through
some architectures on how
you can incorporate them into
your own cloud applications
as well.
But we have the Maps APIs to
start with, so our JavaScript
API or Street View APIs.
These allow you to bring
Maps visualizations
into your application.
But we also have
the Places APIs,
which gives you access to
Google's database of over 100
million points of
interest globally.
And that's business
information, business reviews,
business photos.
We also have an
auto-complete service,
which gives you that familiar
Google type-ahead experience
for address entry.
We have our routing algorithm
and our Directions API
and Distance Matrix
API which draw
upon that real-time
traffic information.
And I'll walk you through a
few of these in more detail.
So what do these
APIs allow you to do?
So, first of all, we
talked about visualization.
Nearly all information
in the world today
has some sort of geospatial
context to it, right?
So the ability to display
this information on a map
allows you to make sense
of this information in ways
that viewing a tabular set of
data doesn't allow you to do.
Second is location services.
What do I mean by
location services?
Well, not everything
needs a map display,
and not every thing has a
display to begin with, right?
So if you're building an
IoT device, for example,
it just needs to know
where it is in the world
and make use of
that information,
make use of that context.
So we give you the
APIs that allow
you to just pull
those data feeds
without the need of a display.
Our APIs give you access to
our movement optimization
algorithms, so our
Driving Directions.
We have a Distance
Matrix API, which
allows you to calculate
actual driving
distance and actual
driving times
using current and
historical traffic data.
And this all comes
together to give you
true location intelligence.
So I think where
the real power comes
in is mixing your own
data, your own customer
data, your own business
data, with Google's data,
rich location data, to actually
form actionable insights that
allow you to make better
business decisions.
So how does this come
together with Cloud?
So we all know that GCP provides
an incredible range of products
and infrastructure for
storage, and for processing,
and machine learning too.
I think where Google
Maps adds value,
and the difference here is our
set of APIs provide content.
It provides content
and data enrichment.
So when you fuse
these two together,
you have a back-end
architecture,
you have Google
content, merged together
in one place with
your own content.
I'm going to walk you through
a few block diagrams which
demonstrate how these
APIs can be used
in a real application
with the cloud,
and walk through, a little
more in detail, some of the use
cases that Adam described,
how you'd actually
go about building
something like this.
So imagine a fleet
tracking application
or connected vehicle
type application.
So you have a vehicle
generating a tremendous amount
of sensor data,
tons of telemetry,
you need to stream
that to the cloud.
So obviously GCP provides
a set of products
to ingest that data.
Things like Pub/Sub
and Dataflow,
that allow you to
ingest that data
and store that data in the
cloud, and query that data.
But if you want to find some
actual insights from that data,
you might need to merge it
with Google's own location data
to add some more value to it.
So what does it allow you to do?
So we have a set of
APIs that will give you
road network understanding.
For example, our speed limit API
to access our speed limit data,
globally, which
would perhaps allow
you to audit your fleet of
drivers for dangerous driving
behavior.
We have something called
a snap-to-road API
so you're getting GPS
positions off these trucks,
you know they're
not going to be--
there's a lot of noise
in the GPS measurements.
So our snap-to-road
API allows you
to snap those to the
nearest road network,
and basically use
Google's road network
to clean up those measurements
that you're taking.
We talked about
the Directions API.
We have an Elevation
API, a global database
of elevation data, that
allow you to figure out
the incline, for example, that
a vehicle might be going on.
And we mentioned the Places API.
You know what Adam
mentioned is, if one
of your drivers and your fleet
is spending a lot of time
in a particular location,
you might want to know,
is it a customer location?
Or is it a local movie theater?
So bringing all of this
data into the cloud
with your own data
would then allow
you to do some very
interesting analytics.
Do the machine learning on it.
Do some visualizations
and make some insights
into your customer operations.
Similarly, internet
of things use
cases is something we're
seeing a lot of excitement
around right now.
We have all these new
connected devices.
Investing in GPS hardware for
a low-cost connected device,
like a wearable,
might be prohibitive.
Our geolocation API is one
of our lesser known APIs,
but it is very powerful.
We have a global database of
millions of Wi-Fi cell towers
which if you have a device
that just has a Wi-Fi internet,
you can query for those
nearby Wi-Fi hotspots,
use our geolocation API to
get a real-time position
of that device in the world.
Another area that we're
seeing a lot of interest
is around Google's capabilities
to standardize and validate
and verify addresses.
So we see this in a number of
different industries right now.
So for example, you may have
used our address autocomplete
service, where you
start typing an address
and Google will provide
a list of suggestions.
Well, it turns out that if
you incorporate that in, say,
an e-commerce flow, for
example, an online store,
using that as part of
your checkout process,
you can decrease shopping cart
abandonment rate and increase
conversion rates, by just
simplifying that checkout
experience.
Especially on mobile
devices, where people may not
be wanting to sit there and
enter multiple address fields.
It also decreases shipping
errors and delivery errors
by having the assurance that
the address has been entered
is correct and exists
within Google's database.
So those are just a
few examples of how
you can incorporate our APIs
in a real-life application.
We have a number of plans
available that scale
with your application.
So we have a generous
free tier that's
suitable for testing and
evaluation of our APIs.
And then we have premium plans
that can have a much higher
daily limits and will
scale with your application
and with your needs.
It's really easy to get started
if you haven't already used
the Maps APIs, just go to
developers.google.com/maps.
This will allow you access
to all of our documentation,
how to create a key.
And getting started
with the APIs
is just as easy, if you're
familiar with the Cloud,
going into the Cloud Console and
activating the APIs right there
and creating a key.
So I'm going to turn it
back over Adam right now.
We talked about some of the
tools, some of the stories,
I think Adam is going to
pull it back together for us
in the story of how
these components can
be used to craft a location
strategy for your business.
ADAM EVANS: Thank you, sir.
Thanks, David.
What I like about what
David's presented here is,
he's showing you the how.
We have a lot of
documentation online
that really allows you
to kind of self-serve
and get into this in depth.
There are Google people around
today and throughout the rest
of the sessions who
can help with the how
to implement some of this.
But just to put bookends
on this session,
I started off
talking about not so
much how to implement
a location strategy,
but why we think that big
businesses and small businesses
and citizens and governments
should consider a location
strategy to make
better decisions.
And to tell the story, I'm
going to relate another customer
engagement we had.
Customer engagement
sounds cheesy.
We got invited to work
with a company that
is almost the opposite
of that small fleet
scenario I gave you.
I was talking a bit about
the company with two or three
florists, or maybe half
a dozen small taxis
or something like that.
This is the inverse.
We were invited to meet
with the CTO of one
of the largest trucking
companies in the world.
And they had an
interesting problem,
and it wasn't one that
you would think off
the top was a technology
problem related
to maps and digital tools.
We got invited to tour
their warehouse where they
service these huge big rigs.
We're talking to big
transport trailers
with very large
engines and large loads
that they would pull over long
haul routes around the world.
With so many trucks
in their fleet,
they had to have very efficient
operations and servicing
systems.
So you can imagine
just how efficient
it was for them to
maintain these trucks.
And he pointed in the corner
at a pallet, a shipping pallet
full of boxes.
And in the boxes were lots
and lots of alternators.
And if you don't know
what an alternator is,
it's like a generator
that recharges
the battery in an engine.
And in a truck,
apparently, these things
are very expensive.
And they were running
into a challenge.
They tried a lot of
different suppliers,
but they were failing.
And they were
failing prematurely,
and they did not know why.
It was costing them some money.
It wasn't breaking
their business,
but it was costing
them some money.
They were having to preemptively
replace the alternators
in every single one
of their trucks,
as they came in for service.
And this was costing them money.
They were buying
more alternators
than they knew
they really needed,
but they did not know when
they were going to fail.
They implemented a Google
Maps-based asset tracking
platform for everything
from their dispatch side
to getting local information
about where a truck was.
But one of the
byproducts of it was
that they were able to get
that ping of information
from the vehicle
every minute or so.
And across all the
trucks, they had
hundreds of millions of points
per day across their fleet.
So they would know at any
moment, every minute or so,
a lot of information
about that vehicle.
So from there they might
get the mass airflow sensor,
which tells you how
hard the driver was
pressing on the throttle.
They might get the fuel level.
They might get the health of
certain sensors in the engine.
And one of the
things they measured
was how much power was
going across that part that
was breaking, how much
electricity voltage was
going through that alternator.
And they started to correlate
it, in a big data effort,
essentially, run on the
Google Cloud platform,
based on the location
data of every single one
of these trucks.
And they started
to see a pattern.
They saw that there
was a voltage drop
in the alternators that failed.
And so they said, oh, I
can smell something here,
there is a smoking gun.
There was a voltage
drop in the ones
that were failing prematurely.
But how do we know which
ones are going to do this?
How do we know when
that voltage drop--
you know, what's
correlated with?
How can we change
driver behavior?
What can we do?
They used the Google Elevation
API, a little-known API
that Google serves that has a
global picture of the mean sea
level, at any position or
latitude and longitude,
you know, the height
above mean sea level.
So you can actually figure
out whether someone's
driving, over a long route,
whether they're generally going
up a grade or down a grade.
And it turns out the vehicles
that spent more than 20%
of their route driving
up a steep grade
were the ones that
saw that voltage drop.
They were able to identify
by doing analytics
on the location of
their entire fleet
and looking at the
sensor information,
looking at the location,
correlating it with context
from Google's
Elevation API, they
were able to preemptively
repair and replace
those alternators that were the
ones that are going to fail.
And they cut down an entire
pallet load every month
of these alternators
that they needed to buy.
Now, the reason I'm
telling you this story
is not because the headline
is "Trucking Company Saves
a Couple Hundred Thousand
Dollars in Alternators."
That's not the headline.
The headline is an alternator
parts supply salesperson
hangs up her phone and says,
you know, I just lost an order.
The trucking
company doesn't want
to buy alternators this
month, or not as many anyway,
and I can't figure out why.
The reason this is important
is that if our premise is right
and that the cost of location is
opening up new business models,
there is an efficiency coming
to virtually every business.
Not just ride share
apps, not just vacation
rental apps, not just
your coffee ordering app,
but to every brick
and mortar business
and traditional old
businesses, location
is starting to force efficiency.
This change will force
all sorts of businesses
to have to include
location in their strategy.
So the question we'd
like to leave people
with after telling stories like
this, and providing some tools,
as David has done in
the how-to, is maybe
when you get back to the office
and you're talking a little bit
about what you learned at Google
Next, ask some of the people
that you work with
how they see location,
and how it works in your world.
You know your business and your
industry and the reality of it
far better than
Google ever would.
But how can location
help you craft a strategy
to get out in front of some
of these big changes that
are coming thanks to optimizing
our business using location?
Thanks, everybody,
for sticking around.
Thank you.